hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today i have something
that i think is going to be
quite fun i'm going to tell you 70
reasons why you
have to get an xbox sony and nintendo
don't want you to know this uh but
seriously i got my hands on an official
xbox magazine
from november 2001 making this a special
preview issue
i have not read through it yet and i
thought it would be very funny
to look at a 2001 take
on 70 reasons why you had to have the
original xbox and like how badly this is
aged
of course i'm not going to go through
all of them we'll pick the highlights
but i think it's going to be a good
time otherwise on the cover it touts
itself as being
the ultimate guide to xbox um
a bunch of like previews of old games as
well this is such a cool thing to have
so let's do it shall we 70 reasons why
you absolutely positively have
to own an xbox this actually seems to be
starting off with digs about it being
299
which like the front page even says at
least the magazine isn't 300
and then this actual feature starts with
you know 299 is a lot of money it's
enough cold
harsh cold hard cash to buy 7176
oreo cookies oh how times have changed
well like 2.99 that's a bargain oh my
god look at the og
xbox dash i can still hear it
this is sort of surprising they've
included the duke
uh number 69 rock solid controller
the first thing you'll notice when you
pick up the xbox game controller is that
it is a
solid heavy feel of course some may call
it bulky
some distractors have commented that
using the xbox game controller
is like playing games with two potatoes
we haven't thought of a snappy comeback
yet i don't know if that's
a good reason to add to your list of 70
that the controller is
excessively large i actually do have
the re-release of the duke somewhere in
my apartment i don't remember where i
put it
that thing is this is also a
particularly weird one
the black and white buttons do you
remember those
why it's important if you are using the
game commander
the black and white buttons will have
the same uses in almost every game push
one and you'll be able to talk directly
to your team push the other and you can
broadcast to everyone in the game
that's what they did what uh if you
don't know what the game commander
is this magazine describes it as
one of the coolest standard peripherals
around my gosh
this is wild to read so the game
commander
is literally a headset which obviously
is a staple now i'm wearing one right
now even though technically
i don't need to hear anything for this
video it says
again 2001. microsoft wants this add-on
to be a major part of its broadband
internet strategy the idea is that
almost every
online game would include support for
the game commander
so that players can communicate as if
they're in the same
room if you've ever played on a network
lan with others within earshot you'll
know how cool this is
and it's so weird to think that there
are people who did grow up playing video
games like more recently that
have never experienced multiplayer games
without a headset
and that this is like this is such a
cool feature that's crazy
oh it does also know microsoft is
seriously considering supporting voice
modulation that would enable you to
change your voice in real time
with some clever programming you could
taunt your enemies with the menacing
tone of darth vader or the high-pitched
shouts of screech i don't know if they
ever did that oh my god
memory cards and controllers i had
completely forgotten this was a thing
three things really stand out when you
talk about the xbox memory cards it's
cool that the console supports them even
though it already has a hard drive
which was a big deal back in the day two
memory cards can fit in each controller
which facilitates easy file swapping
and the memory cards can be safely
stowed in the controller so they're not
easily misplaced
holy [ __ ] that is so wild oh my god
hard drive interface here we go this
is already jesus just mind-blowing stuff
the xbox was intelligently designed to
make use of
the hard drive and just because it's a
microsoft product doesn't mean that it
has to be as confusing as your garden
variety pc
operating system yeah the hard drive was
really cool and the fact that you could
move stuff around was really cool
but it's just so strange to see a hard
drive written out as a selling feature
and also read a magazine saying that pc
operating systems are confusing where
hard drives are concerned
are they though i don't know if that's
true oh
hd tv support all right let's show you
the art for this next page here
wow beautiful stuff one of the key
values that shaped the development of
the xbox
was a look to the future of hd tv right
out of the box the xbox is ready to
support the format
it may take several years for this to
become an important feature to the
average developer but it's good to know
that it's there
wow they thought hd was good
it says it supports 720
and 1080i progressive scan
oh you little cutie this next part talks
about max resolution and says
the xbox maximum resolution of 1920x1080
is a glimpse of the future
holy [ __ ] god bless old video game
magazines
for gems like this like this is so fun
to read right now
it does also list under the resolution
one one of the key problems with the
playstation
2 architecture is memory issues because
of this it is extremely difficult for
developers to use high resolution
textures
in their playstation 2 games even if the
ps2 could match the xbox's highest
resolutions which it can't
the textures would still look dark and
grainy i did not know that to be fair i
was
uh eight when this magazine came out i
did have an original xbox on launch
because my step dad
got it like for free with a phone like
it was like a bundle deal
um so i feel like i don't remember a lot
of the marketing at all i just remember
the games that i chose to play i don't
remember resolutions being important to
me as an eight-year-old
all right one or another page here we're
get we're getting into our 30s
apparently
boom look at that art design you nailed
it
this also mentions the hard drive really
not a great list
really the list the list has some flaws
for the first time ever in video game
history a major console will ship with a
built-in hard drive
which as time will tell should become
the most valuable asset in the xbox
arsenal
it's something no other console of this
generation can offer
that's nuts and and to think that now
we're like
bro but why is it only got one terabyte
do you know how fast that's going to
fill up though
what am i supposed to do with just one
terabyte wait they have the hard drive
built in again
how many times are you going to mention
the hard drive all right come on
get a new job they probably have a new
job i guess at least this one is
specifying that the hard drive is built
in
32 massive streaming worlds typically
the size of a game level is determined
by two things game design and memory
space it takes time to spool level
information off a disk in fact games are
often broken down into levels to allow
for loading times because information
spawns off the hard drive more quickly
developers will be able to create
xbox games as worlds that are much
larger than anything we've seen before
i don't know if i would call that
massive streaming worlds
uh that means a different thing in 2020
that sentence hasn't aged well that's so
cool
they have a fable screenshot here that
is listed as
project ego still not even called fable
it's just project ego broadband adapter
and internet downloads can you believe
it
okay by adopting a broadband strategy
microsoft has freed up developers to
focus on the best performing multiplayer
action possible without having to
reverse engineer their games to work on
dial up modems
that are already too slow for um
hardcore action gaming i really want to
read internet downloads what you got for
me bro
holy [ __ ] this rules
it's so funny to read okay of course
this is a while off
but as soon as there is a solid working
infrastructure for broadband internet
even that was a while off oh my god our
xbox units will be ready to plug in and
download stuff off of the internet such
as roster updates
new levels and even
demos could you imagine if we could
download
a demo i wonder if they genuinely had
no concept of the fact that we would be
able to download
an entire video game in 2001.
was that just incomprehensible what is
incomprehensible to us now what am i
going to be wrong about
in 20 years time another page featuring
your boy shrek let's see it shadows
why it's important when done correctly
shadows are an absolutely essential part
of a realistic looking video game and
that it explicitly
references shrek after just talking
about
realistic looking video games do have
nice shadows
they also have pixel shaders vertex
shaders anti-aliasing
polygon throughput texture compression
simultaneous textures simultaneous
textures and reflection mapping this is
so cool top of the list here we go
let's do it okay number nine the sounds
of silence
one of the first things you notice about
the xbox or should we say one of the
first things you won't notice about the
xbox is the machine's quiet
sound still definitely an
issue eight microsoft isn't going away
any time soon
seven it's easy to develop for six
massive marketing budget why is that a
reason to own one
it's a weird thing to write you weird
journalist number five developer support
developers in the us and europe have
embraced xbox and at this time we know
of more than 200 titles in development
can you imagine if we knew of 200 titles
in development for the xbox series x
or the playstation 5 they're so
tight-lipped this generation it sucks
full you'll be able to get one sony
promised the world and then failed to
deliver enough units when it introduced
the playstation 2
which i feel like xbox series x is going
to do this time
we're not going to get enough units
three the future the best days of the
xbox are certainly ahead of us the first
wave of games will only give us a
glimpse of what's on the way
and developers are just now starting to
grasp the amazing power of this system
incredible number one two is a dumb joke
about how your grandma could sit on it
for some reason
number one is the games let's face it
despite the xbox's many strengths
if it didn't have the games it wouldn't
be worth your time they list dead or
alive three mad dash
amped freestyle snowboarding nhl hits
halo
dave mirror bmx tony hawk's pro skater 2
oddworld munch odyssey madden 2002 air
force delta storm project gotham racing
shout out to predict gotham racing cell
damage wwf
raw is war and nfl fever wow
it's one of those taco bell ads they
still do taco bell integrations that's a
long ongoing like marketing partnership
damn
this has been very fun to read this is
it's so
also just a bit mortifying because this
is absolutely going to um
happen to me like you'll read something
that i wrote
forever ago and be like did they not
know about like the future
because of course they can't know about
the future so yeah that's uh
that's it for this video i just thought
this would be really fun to read
and it was i had a great time i'm aware
that visually this video is me reading
a magazine um what else am i supposed to
do you know
that's what i'm saying but uh huge
thanks
to the subscriber who sent me this um
massively appreciate it this is so cool
and
very funny and will only get funnier i
hope you guys enjoyed this
very silly video as we head into an
entirely new generation of consoles and
make more outdated content that will
make us look stupid in 19 years
i can't wait but can you guys imagine if
maybe one day
we could download game demos
hard drives bro